Last week, the Internet got its
first look at the movie remake
of anime favorite Ghost in the
Shell, which is really awesome,
and you should watch the
original if you haven't seen it.
People can't stop talking
about the casting
for this new movie.
The roll of ass-kicking
Japanese cyborg
Major Motoko Kusanagi
will be played
by notable Japanese actress,
Scarlett Johansson.
(laughter)
-Look how Japanese she is not.
-(laughter)
Now, maybe
the movie will be good.
I don't know.
I haven't seen it yet.
But why did they do this?
Did the studio misread
Scarlett Johansson's
-last name as Johan-san?
-(laughter)
Like, I don't know
how they made this mistake.
Between this,
Emma Stone in Aloha,
and Natalie Dormer
in The Forest,
we almost have enough actresses
to do an all-white-female
Seven Samurai reboot,
so let's really
get behind this, guys.
Come on. It's time.
(applause and cheering)
So, since apparently,
studios will cast
just whomever--
parenthesis, white people--
as whatever,
comedians, what's another
controversial casting choice?
Anna.
-Kevin James as Godzilla.
-(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
Yup. Points.
-Ben. -Kylie Jenner
as someone with human lips.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
(applause and cheering)
-Flula. -Donald Trump as the
president of the United States.
-HARDWICK: Oh, don't go...
-AKANA: Oh!
Okay. Okay.
-Okay. Points.
-Is this...?
-HARDWICK: Yeah. -Wait.
Is this fiction or non-fiction?
-Is it fic...?
-HARDWICK: It's actually...
It wa fiction.
It's slowly becoming
non-fiction.
-AKANA: I know.
-BORG: That is very scary.
-HARDWICK: It's turning.
-Oh, it's a new...
HARDWICK: Everyone thought
it would be fiction,
and now it doesn't seem...
We don't (bleep) know what's
gonna happen anymore.
GLEIB: Trump probably thinks
he can be in this movie.
(imitating Trump):
I'd be a great Asian girl.
HARDWICK:
Yeah, I could be an Asian girl.
What's wrong?!
I've been evicting ghosts
-from shells for years!
-(laughter)